europa sigue siendo el foco de atención
del planeta kobe de la mutación del
virus ocurrida en una población de
visones en dinamarca ha sido también
detectada en 214 personas que trabajan
en granjas me gustaría recordarles que
las mutaciones son normales este tipo de
cambios en el virus es algo que hemos
estado rastreando desde el principio
ming el reino unido tiene el mayor
número de muertes por cop 19 en europa
en consecuencia a gran bretaña lanzó un
plan piloto de pruebas masivas en la
ciudad de liverpool este viernes
ofreciendo a todos pruebas tengan unos
síntomas así creo personalmente que
cualquier cosa que nos devuelva a una
vida normal es algo bueno realmente en
mi opinión no dependiendo no estoy
diciendo que no lo haría obviamente me
gustaría saber un poco más al respecto
pero si nos ayuda a volver a una vida
normal entonces estoy feliz por algo así
de verdad el programa es un intento del
gobierno británico de encontrar una
nueva forma de utilizar las pruebas para
limitar la propagación del coronavirus
mientras el país conoce su segundo
cierre nacional desde este
también desde el jueves italia
experimentó toques de queda de las 10 de
la noche a las 5 de la mañana y desde
hoy italia está dividida en tres con
regiones amarillas naranjas y rojas
según los indicadores de peligrosidad
que maneja el gobierno y que han
desatado críticas la diferenciación y
trauma regional creo que poner algunas
regiones en la zona roja y excluir otras
no es una solución
mucha gente lo ve como una decisión
injusta y de hecho es un poco injusta si
decides que el bloqueo debe aplicarse a
todos en cualquier caso no hemos
aprendido nada de la experiencia que
tuvimos en marzo y te queda marzo de
bueno que habíamos visto tomar son
alguien muy padre y para poniente
hoy italia superó 40.000 muertos y es el
segundo país después del reino unido